we're called night gardeners
because we work underground
it's dark it's gotten dark it
's dark
so working underground is the
best way to grow champions
this
dirt 2 freestone d  humility and
manure the champion must take this taste
there
but the champion has infiltrated and in
the air his friends call me angèle
briolet I am hills champion
we let time we let
nature take its course and then we will harvest  for
four weeks four good weeks
we are not in the race or who are hostages
to the yield here it is above all the taste
that will take precedence must let this
taste take hold and this time
now my milk
industrial techniques Dutch method are at
the  outside that is to say it is a guy
or a large isolated greenhouse managed by
computer with an air conditioning could not have the
same artisanal methods as me
I learned that I do what
I continued to defend my profession
underground Malian in the method
traditional
good I've always known this
activity this job upstream
I've always been passionate about children I was born
into a family of champions lists have
crawled was champion read my parents
my uncles the whole family
well I'm in  the last ones it's true
because there was a low a few
years ago when we were at rillieux the
competition of industrial mushrooms
which was born at low prices so many
championships in France have closed
that's the damage because  there is a whole knowledge
that is going to be lost
that there you are happy it is when
you see this champion evolve who comes out
of the earth very small you see him
every day also to get bigger grow bigger
has reached maturity that's where you are
happy or you there you see you have
worked that your work has been well
done